CAPTURED.
ANOTHER PERSON OF INTEREST
DETAINED.
CORRESPONDENT CASEY STEAGALL IS
IN THE AREA WITH THE LATEST.
>> Reporter: THIS JUST IN FROM
JAKE GIBSON, ONE OF OUR INTREPID
PRODUCERS THERE IN D.C. WHERE HE
SAID THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, THE
U.S. JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS HAVE TOLD FOX NEWS
THAT FEDERAL CHARGES ARE VERY
MUCH UNDER CONSIDERATION HERE.
AT THIS AS AUTHORITIES TONIGHT
ARE STILL PROCESSING THAT
MASSIVE CRIME SCENE NOT FAR FROM
WHERE I AM OVER AT THE
HIGH SCHOOL.
ALSO, DIGGING DEEP INTO THE
17-YEAR-OLD GUNMAN'S PAST, WHICH
WE ARE TOLD DID NOT RAISE MANY
RED FLAGS PRIOR TO THIS MORNING.
>> WE COME TOGETHER TODAY AS WE
DEAL WITH ONE OF THE MOST
HEINOUS ATTACKS THAT WE HAVE
EVER SEEN IN THE HISTORY OF
TEXAS SCHOOLS.
>> Reporter: IN EARLY MORNING
TRAGEDY ON TEXAS' GULF COAST
AFTER POLICE SAY A MALE STUDENT
WALKED INTO A HIGH SCHOOL ART
CLASS WITH A SHOTGUN AND
REVOLVER AND OPENED FIRE.
THEY SAY IT WAS A SCENE OF CHAOS
AND CONFUSION.
>> SEVERAL OF MY FRIENDS GOT
SHOT, AND AS SOON AS THE ALARM
WENT OFF, EVERYBODY RAN OUTSIDE.
AND I JUST RAN AS FAST AS I
COULD.
>> I JUST RAN AS FAST AS I
>> IT WAS SCARY, I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO.
>> THE ATTACK HAPPENED AT
7:30 A.M. FRIDAY MORNING AT
SANTA FE HIGH SCHOOL IN THE
SMALL CITY OF SANTA FE, 35 MILES
SOUTHEAST OF HOUSTON.
WITNESSES SAY THAT AT FIRST THEY
THOUGHT IT WAS A FIRE DRILL.
>> THE FIRE ALARM WAS PULLED AND
WE WERE TOLD TO GO OUTSIDE.
WE GOT A FEW GUARD SHOTS.
>> Reporter: POLICE SAY HE MAY
HAVE BEEN PLANNING SOMETHING
MORE SINISTER.
THERE HAVE BEEN EXPLOSIVE
DEVICES FOUND IN THE HIGH SCHOOL
AND SURROUNDING AREAS.
>> Reporter: THIS IS A FOURTH
FATAL SCHOOL SHOOTING IN THE
UNITED STATES THIS YEAR.
THOSE IN THE COMMUNITY ARE
SHOCKED IT HAPPENED IN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
>> IF THIS CAN HAPPEN AND
SANTA FE, IT CAN HAPPEN IN
ANYWHERE.
>> I SHOULDN'T BE GOING THROUGH
THIS AT MY SCHOOL.
LIKE THIS IS MY DAILY LIFE, I
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO FEEL LIKE
THAT.
AND I FEEL SCARED TO EVEN GO
BACK.
>> Bret: INVESTIGATORS SAY
THAT THE GUNMAN HAD TWO WEAPONS
ON HIM.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT BOTH BELONGED
TO THE SUSPECTS FATHER AND THEY
WERE LEGALLY ACQUIRED.
IN ADDITION TO THE TEN PEOPLE
WHO LOST THEIR LIVES HERE TODAY,
TEN OTHERS WERE SERIOUSLY HURT,
INCLUDING A SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICER WHO WAS SHOT WHILE
TRYING TO HELP THE SUSPECT.
BRET, TONIGHT HE HAS BEEN
CREDITED AS A HERO AND CREDITED
WITH SAVING MANY MORE LIVES.
BACK TO YOU.
>> Bret: CASEY, AN ARRAIGNMENT
FOR THE SUSPECT?
>> Reporter: WE UNDERSTAND
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN
WITHIN THE HOUR.
HE IS IN CUSTODY WITHIN
GALVESTON COUNTY AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT ARRAIGNMENT IS
SCHEDULED TO HAPPEN SOMETIME
WITHIN THE NEXT 45 MINUTES OR
SO, BEING CHARGED WITH CAPITAL
MURDER AND AGGRAVATED ASSAULT OF
A POLICE OFFICER, IN ADDITION TO
WHAT I SAID AT THE TOP OF THE
BROADCAST.
THAT INFORMATION CAME FROM JAKE